the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I'm going to do two things in
particular one is finish off with the
discussion of this device a shaker this
by the way this is a commercial thing
and out of the catalogue this is the
littlest one they make this is called
this is a 50 pound shaker at full speed
it actually puts out 50 pounds just with
all it is as masses inside going round
and round
what's its commercial purpose well the
big ones that are better maybe a you
know hundred pounds of moving mass are
they bolt them to the floor in nuclear
power plants and test them shape the
buildings to represent earthquake kind
of loads and things like that okay and
the smaller ones you can buy these for
this kind is actually if you're running
an operation like in a flour mill and
you've got particulate stuff trying to
get it to slide through shoots does
stuff slide down shoots easier if the
things are vibrating a little bit have
you ever banged on something to get
stuff to come loose you just stick one
of these on the side might it run
nothing sticks so there's a lots and
lots of purposes for shakers like this
so we were in the process of analyzing
how one of these works
and I want to finish that off and then
part two today is we're going to you
know we've only really talked about
angular momentum with respect to
particles individual particles and even
in your physics classes you did things
with mass moments of inertia and so
we're going to make the connection today
between particles mass moments of
inertia unbalanced shakers it all comes
together in one in and in the second
part of today's lecture so the the
problem we are analyzing here that
literally that little shaker can be
modeled well in that one particular
application we can find that thing on
rollers this is the problem we were
discussing it has inside of it an
unbalanced rotating mass with an arm
with a long it's called the eccentricity
in the trade and it has some mass m and
the optin this body that it's in we'll
call it mass of the body MB and this
thing's going around and round so this
is some angle theta which is described
as it make a T and it's their constant
rotation rate devices so theta dot
equals Omega and that's a constant which
how they're basically designed and we
labeled this point a over here we have a
inertial coordinate system XY this point
a this point we've called B in our
analysis and we set out to find the
equation of motion of this thing in the
X Direction has no movement in the Y
it's confined in the Y it puts out lots
of force in the Y direction you really
have to restrain it to keep from moving
but it doesn't move in the Y direction
but it will move in the in the X ok
so we came to the conclusion that we
could write for the main body the
summation of the external forces on MB
is just MB times its acceleration and
its accelerated completely defined by
dis coordinate we if we draw a free body
diagram of this mass you're going to
have a normal force so I'll call n in
the Y Direction upwards you're going to
have its weight downwards and you're
going to have some force exerted on it
through this shaft that comes from the
little mass so we're accounting for
everything the little mass all its
influence on this made big block by the
forces that are passed through that rod
which is hinged at the center okay and
I'm going to call that F and B okay the
force on that from that little link now
that happens to be equal to minus the
forces on the mass that this rod exerts
it must exert some force on the mass to
make it go around and round okay and
because of Newton's third law those two
forces have to be equal and opposite
because they're operating on the same
massless shaft for the purpose of this
example okay so that's basically so this
is in order to find that equation of
motion the sum of the external forces
these are both in the Y direction so we
just need to find the horizontal
component
of this force and will be able to
complete that equation so the export the
exercise here is just to find this
horizontal component so to do that let's
move on to thinking about the little
mass small mass and what its Freebody
diagram looks like
so viewed from the here's our rod here's
the small mass this is a side view so
there's a point it's rotating about a
but I want to draw a Freebody diagram on
of this rod if there's going to be the
rod puts a force on this mass which will
have a vertical component F M and I'll
just call it Y and it'll put a force
that's an horizontal component F M X and
I'm putting I'm writing them drawing
them both positive because I don't know
which direction they act and if the
answer turns out to be positive then I
guessed right if it's negative it means
it's going the other way and what other
forces are acting on this well there is
certainly is an mg downwards acting on
that mass okay and there's no forces in
and out of the page on it okay and it's
operating in the plane so this is what
one of planar motion problem and we note
that in here r dot equals R double dot
equals zero the change this thing
doesn't change in length at all it's
just going round and round fixed length
so this we can write then that the
summation of the external forces on this
little Mass better equal its mass times
the acceleration of point a with respect
to the inertial frame and whoops not a
but what
be the acceleration at this point this
is B we need to figure out what the
acceleration of that point is in the
inertial frame but we've done enough of
these problems that this is should be
pretty easy this is the mass times the
acceleration of point a with respect to
O plus the mass times the acceleration
of B with respect to a B and a these are
all vectors until I break them down into
their x and y components so what's the
acceleration of a with respect to O in
the coordinate systems that we have
written here so that's just kind of our
generic representation of acceleration
right but we've chosen some coordinates
here specifically have a coordinate to
discourage the motion of the main mass
right what is that so what's the
acceleration of point a X double dot so
we know that this then is M X double dot
and Plus now since it's easy just to
describe this in terms of cylindrical
coordinates and we can then write that
well then this must be a mass times the
are the terms in the R hat direction
our hat and then terms over here in the
theta hat direction theta double dot
plus 2 r dot theta dot now which of
these are 0 does it radius is our arm
change length no so this is 0 is that is
the angular velocity I ranked the
Coriolis is 0 so isn't Coriolis force
nor Alerian force no radial acceleration
only a single term just its centripetal
so this becomes a pretty pretty simple
expression so the summation of the
external forces on our little mass then
we can write as M X double dot in the I
hat direction
I'm going to break it into its vector
components here minus M and I know that
our here equals e that's the
eccentricity and I can start using these
terms minus M e awared r hat but I'm
going to break that R goes round and
round I need to break it into x and
y-components but we've done that many
times before that looks like a cosine
Omega T in the I hat direction plus a
sine Omega T in the J hat direction
so as this thing goes round and round
I've got the cosine term and a sine term
and this is in the X direction this
isn't the y
so we're really interested in the
equation of motion on small mass M in
the x-direction so we just need to pull
out the X components from this so we
have an M X double dot I hat minus M
Omega squared cosine Omega T I hat we
can drop the I hats now because we just
have one single component equation and
this is this quantity I called FM X and
FM xn is the X term in my little
Freebody diagram and the force that it
exerts on the main mass is in the X
direction so this is the force that the
rod places on that little mass in the X
direction what's the force that the rod
places on the big mass in the X
Direction minus that okay so this is
minus F and B in the X direction and
that's what we're after
we need that force so that we can go
back now and finish out our the equation
of motion that we were after for the
main mass this up here we need to sum
the external forces to get that fill out
that expression but while I'm here just
to have it the summation of the forces
on the small mass in the Y direction
look at our free body diagram it has a
minus mg and it then has this term minus
m e Omega squared sine Omega T
so just for completeness we have a also
the y component of the force that the
rod places on the small mass and minus
this amount is what it places on the
main mass that it's connected to so now
let's go back to our equation up here
the summation of the forces on the main
body in the x-direction
it's going to be the main body x
double-dot
and it's now the x-direction forces it's
only there's only complex component of
this force and that's what we have right
here it's minus that
and that's our equation of motion we can
rearrange it a little bit and it
remarkably simplifies actually you end
up if you collect the motion terms
involving X on the left hand side equals
an external excitation on the right hand
side and that's Eddy there's been viewed
kind of following the commentaries and
enbe a little confusion about some
questions when you're asked find an
equation of motion is that the same
thing as meaning find the motor going to
solve the equation of motion no ask him
find the equation of motion it means get
this far now if I want to know a
solution for this pretty trivial in this
case it's going to look like cosine
Omega T but then I'd then you'd I'd say
solve that equation of motion okay now
let's see we also know just finish this
that the summation of the forces on this
main body in the Y direction must be
zero because it can't move no
acceleration and from the free body
diagram for that we can write that this
is n + y - MBG
- mg from the little mass plus M e Omega
squared sine Omega T it's the other
phase of this and the interesting thing
here then is to solve for the force that
it takes to hold this thing in place so
you get M B plus M times G Plus or -
right yeah
all right so what's that so this kind of
looks Thep back and look at these things
and say what's it telling us so first of
all just to keep this thing from moving
up and down there's if there's a force
on it that has to support its weight and
it's the combined weight of whatever's
inside that container the weight of the
rotating mass and the weight of the
object they have to be supported by a
normal force which is this is a constant
term weight down normal force up and
around that constant force is an
oscillating force M Omega squared sine
Omega T Omega squared after you should
recognize as a centripetal acceleration
mass times acceleration to force and
because it goes round and round it's
when it's it like this it's pulling up
and one's like this it's pulling down
one it's like this it's only going
through the side so that sine Omega T
for the vertical parts cosine Omega T
for the horizontal and that's actually
all there is to the shake that's all
there that's that's all the rest of
these checkers they're rotating mass
inside now what in the homework from the
second homework where you had this thing
this ball running around inside where I
posed the question in a way I didn't
really quite intend but I asked
here's the track and yet this roller
going around inside and I asked to find
the normal force that the track exerts
on the roller so it's a nun nun and
there must also be a tangential force on
this thing and there's also going to be
this thing certainly has weight mg and
that's so that's the complete free body
diagram now let's call if this is
frictionless which it won't be reality
but for the purposes of analysis we'll
say it frictionless so it's only a
normal force where does this tangential
force come from why is it there in this
problem there's a key piece of
information you're told and that is that
the angular acceleration of this thing
is constant its constant speed going
around if you had a ball rolling around
there a constant speed would it would it
want to would it go constant if you just
push it and it started rolling which
slow down going up and it was feet up
coming down why gravity right so there
must be something that has to overcome
gravity going uphill and holding it back
coming downhill so the way these things
actually work is they've got ports push
and compressed air in here and this is
driven around by compressed air and
there's different there's a pressure
difference doing this side in that side
and that generates the necessary
tangential force to make the thing go
around and around but they're really
easy to make you can imagine very few
moving parts just hook up a compressed
air hose to that and it's just pushing
the ball around the inside you get the
same outcome okay so the on this ball on
this roller if there is a we the problem
that we just saw
is we found F em in the Y and F em in
the X and this problem said yeah but I
can't get the same thing but have those
coordinates be F normal and F tangential
sure that's just a coordinate rotation
so you can what can you say about these
forces well one thing you could say is F
N squared plus F T squared that better
be equal to F em x squared plus F M Y
squared right and then just like
converting from polar to Cartesian
coordinates you can do these conversions
and you could find out for example that
F n is keep my notation consistent here
f n will be F M in the X cosine Omega T
plus F M in the Y sine Omega T and so
there's the answer that you this is what
you're asked for in that problem
okay so that's you now you need all you
need to know about shakers if you if
you're ever confronted with something
like this you know what's the magnitude
of the force that the shaker puts out
little louder M R Omega squared but
substitute for are the actual
eccentricity its whatever that mass in
length is out there that's spinning
around M I Omega squared is the
magnitude of the force and it's going to
oscillate up and down and it's going to
have gravity that it adds to but the
important part is any Omega squared is
the magnitude of the force okay we're
going to now we're going to move on to
the next topic the next topic is mass
moments of inertia and it has a strong
connection to these and I'm going to use
this kind of analysis as the transition
to talking about moments of inertia
moments of inertia and products of
inertia so any final questions about
this before we go on yeah quite and I
clewd mg in the Oh this is that yeah
you're right and what is my Freebody
diagram it
has it on it right and he just didn't
get it down and into the end what
directions it in okay because then we
did get it back in it back in the last
line for the y-component now it does it
appear in this come in this one this
equation at all there's absolutely
nothing to do it gravity is in the Jade
or J hat direction this is a force
equation in I hat but it does appear in
that normal tangential expression when
you go look at the solution for that
problem because it has components in
both of the I and J directions and so
it'll it'll show up gravity will show up
in this expression right through this
term yeah yep hi this is 0
I left the end where it wasn't moved
everything the other side so this beat
that plus we come to minus these okay
which
right they should be should be - this
thing a summation here this force is
minus the little mass four so we that
ought to become a plus in a plus right
and so if I do that carefully then
this one is okay but this one's got
appears to have a sign problem right but
these two terms have got to be the same
and so I've got a mistake somewhere and
rather than spend 10 minutes fixing it
on the fly take I'll take note of that
the this should be okay
ah wait a second - no no I'm not going
to try to fix it right now I made it so
I've made a slip in my notes somewhere
but I will repair that yeah yeah
yeah okay but so you're asking if
gravity is not taken into account
somehow by that rotating the
gravitational force that is on the main
mass that comes from the little mass
certainly has to pass through the rod
right it's got to be contained in the
forces in the connecting rod so it's
definitely there but the force that's
caused that causes a centripetal
acceleration of that rotating mass has
is completely independent of gravity
with or without gravity it takes a
particular force to make that thing
travel in a circular path and that's M
minus M R theta dot squared always yep
on which expression this one okay this
is the total forces on the little mass
we need to back up to here the total
forces are mass times the acceleration
of the main body it's connected to plus
the mass times the acceleration of B
with respect to a so we have to have
that term and we then go into our four
terms here and find there's only one
left so that's the force exerted on the
small mass by the rod and that is
positive MX double dot minus M R theta
dot squared so we sum the forces on that
little mass it is got to be equal to ah
I know whoever made the mistake okay so
we've just discovered our mistake this
has got to be able to mass times
acceleration and what are the forces
the summation of the forces is mass
times acceleration so that's the
acceleration is this Plus this but the
sum of the forces
to know whether the problem here is I've
used a notation where it's this is very
similar looking to the forces that I've
noted here so this is the actual force
in the y-direction J hat plus the actual
force in the X direction I hat minus mg
I so when I solve for the I component
I'm going to get the I pieces of that
plus mg I I mean excuse the J component
should be like that
the J component will have this piece
times sine Omega T with a minus and you
move the m gj2 that side and it becomes
a plus alright that makes sense
the rod has to hold up the weight of
that little mass right the weights down
but the rod has to push up on it in the
Y direction so the force the rod it puts
it on the little mass has got to be
equal to the weight of the small mass
minus this mi Omega squared term which
is the centripetal is the force
necessary to create the centripetal
acceleration okay so we've got this now
fixed this term is okay
and the - that force is then the force
on the main body so - Plus now I've got
to figure out what we I did wrong here
we're still wish that if you're doing
when I said I wasn't adieu we're on the
fly trying to figure out where they okay
you're happy now
good okay all right we're going to move
on
yeah what about the summation right fair
enough
yep this is just minus F well this is
the on the little mass this is the force
on the little mass from the Freebody
diagram right and that helps distant
that's different from the summation one
here okay all right I think we got to
start it out now do we have we'll use
this I've put on the stellar website
under readings a little one-page thing
called moments of inertia it's a it's
it's two pages of information taken from
the Williams textbook on dynamics and
I'm just kind of show you it's going to
show some of what I'm going to put on
the board especially the detailed stuff
you don't have to copy okay we're going
to come up some expressions for angular
momentum in terms of particles and their
positions and we're this is now the
subject of mass and moments of inertia
and products of inertia and I'm going to
put some of these equations on the board
you don't have to copy them all these
all these expressions become the
definitions of mass moments of inertia
and products of inertia and if you strop
down in one last little bit we come up
with an expression for angular momentum
three vector components look like ixx
omega x plus i X Y Omega Y and so forth
and they components in terms of particle
masses and positions are defined in
these final equations so we're going to
make that so I'm going to tell you what
I'm going to tell you we're going to
make the transition from from dealing
with
particles and angular momentum of
particles too angular momentum of rigid
bodies okay and I in my own experience
this is something that is generally done
badly and I'm going to try to do it well
okay I'm going to try to give you an
intuitive understanding of why we have
these diagonal terms called the moments
of inertia and what they're useful for
and why these off diagonal terms call
products of inertia turn up and what
they actually mean when I was taught
this stuff I never got a gut feeling for
why or what the off-diagonal terms meant
you don't know it but we've been using
them and then I'll tell you the answer
the answer is that when we have a
problem like well the one the motorcycle
problem is this that we were talking
about is this basically here's the
motorcycle wheel spinning around and
round and it has these two masses this
is I set up B so one little mass was off
to the side of the rim a bit and the
other mass is off to the side thinking
yeah and the picture it looked like this
here's the axle motorcycle the fork
should be coming down like this and he's
too little masses a sequal distance but
opposite sides from one another and if
this spins it puts a heck of a wobble
into this thing okay
and it's these it's these if this puts a
moment about this point it tries to make
this thing rock back and forth as it's
spinning it's really hard to hold you
hold the axle here and I got to do it so
you don't get hit by the yeah there you
go
now tell me if you feel a moment it's
really our key hard to keep the thing
from straight right well that's what
it's trying to do to that motorcycle
wheel all right okay for this problem
those eye those off die
will terms the products of inertia are
not zero okay the product of inertia
terms cause these things called dynamic
imbalances it causes there to be angular
momentum terms instead of the angular
momentum being aligned with the axis of
rotation the rotation vector it's
pointed off in this direction
any time that happens you anytime the
angular momentum vector and the rotation
vector are not aligned you will have off
diagonal terms and you will have dynamic
imbalance okay so there's a physical
consequence of those off diagonal terms
and they explain the dynamic imbalance
so let's see if we can't make some some
headway on that they've seen the rotor
let's look at two cases
one that looks like that which I just
had set up a second ago and what it
looks like that call this a B and the in
both cases the rotation is around a
vertical axis and it's constant at Omega
and I just mean these to be two
different cases I'll make it lowercase
so it'll confuse it with my coordinate
system notation this is going to be
point a and this and both of these
problems and it's there's going to be
it's going to be the origin of the
coordinate system so if you cause this
to spin these are these both have that I
write these masses is M over 2 well from
this for a moment let's just think of
these as being equal masses if you do
this problem this do you think this one
will wobble no it's perfectly balanced
and it will just spin nice and smoothly
it has angular momentum around the z
axis the omega axis it has angular
momentum in that direction certainly we
can calculate it this one has this
masses same mass same distance away from
this axis but now one up and one down
this one wobbles and this one but if
this one has a component of angular
momentum that's in this direction was
exactly equal to this one but this one
also has a component that's it's in this
direction and we're going to figure take
a look and see what that is so we're
going to do this problem here I think
that's
we're going to analyze B this case B and
here's the goal the goal is to show you
that the angular momentum of this system
with respect to this point can be
written as a matrix with constants in it
which we call the mass moment of inertia
matrix times a vector the vector
components of the rotation rate now this
problem the z axis will be upwards and
will only have one component one nonzero
component but in general we want to be
able to express the angular momentum as
a product of this inertia matrix and
these are the nurses we'll find out with
respect to a times a vector of angular
velocities we've got to be very careful
about some definitions it's
so we're going to do this specific
problem but it has we're going to use
methods that are completely general so I
want to describe the general problem
here is a inertial coordinate system
fixed here's a body out here in space
and it is rotating about some point a so
point one and the rotation vector the
angular rotation is some Omega and it's
just in some direction and that Omega is
with respect we always in these angular
momentum problems define rotation rate
with respect to an inertial coordinate
system now this point a so first
carefully define a is a fix point so is
it an inertial point yeah any you can do
Lutins laws from this point just as well
as it could any fix any fixed point in
this inertial reference frame is an
inertial point and you can use Newton's
laws so this is a fixed point of
defining it that way
this body is rotating about that point
with this angular rate okay but attached
to the body is a
coordinate system that rotates with the
body so this will be some a XYZ
coordinate system attached to the body
so it's like this problem where I've got
a rope to a coordinate system attached
to my wheel there's X Y or Y or Z coming
out of it and in really simple case it's
rotating around the z axis but I could
say I can make it rotate around some
other axis I pushed a nail through here
and I'm trying to hold it constant here
now it's rotating about a different axis
right same rotation rate but you know
it's not necessarily it doesn't have to
be lined up in any pretty way I get if I
make that thing rotate around that other
axis it looks weird but we can define it
and that's what we're talking about here
so this body is rotating around some and
some rotation rate with respect to a
reference frame attached to the body so
a XYZ is a frame I can't can't make this
go up
I'm on this is attached to the body okay
and not I'm just what I've drawn them a
kind of funny angles here just to
emphasize that they're not necessarily
lined up with these and there and it's
can rotate okay Omega
just emphasize it's always in the
inertial frame okay
last point which will get may be
confusing to start with Omega measured
with respect to O can be expressed in
terms of the a XYZ unit vectors okay
we're going to do that it turns out is
vastly simplifies the problem to to
express the rotation in the unit vectors
of the frame attached to the body
remember that frame is still fit it has
its origin a is at a fixed point in the
inertial frame so it's just the rotor
systems going around and you can in
there inside of that system you have a
rotation and you can break it down into
little XYZ components it's just a vector
and you can express it in those
components that's all we're saying here
now I want to look in I want to do the
motorcycle problem let's turn it on its
side and the reason I'm going to do this
specific example of the hope here is to
actually now give you a physical feeling
what for what's going on we've done a
lot of a lot of illustrations of it and
you know that it produces imbalances so
here's my z-axis and my rotation rate
Omega with respect to O is some Omega in
the K hat direction in the fixed ring
and in my in this case I'm going to it's
going to be simpler than the general
case so that we can do it in a
reasonable length of time so actually as
here's my rod here's my point a this is
my coordinate system a X Y Z okay so
this is now in attached to the body my
body is my rigid body is a massless rod
with two masses on it okay and this
distance this is the X going that way
will be a Y which we have little use of
there's nothing happening in that
direction so this distance here I'll
call x1 this distance here is z1 over
here this is Z 2 and X 2 now we're going
to make this probably it will substitute
in numbers so this is symmetric so X 2
is going to be minus X 1 and so forth
but we don't have to do that we don't
want to keep them separate for the
moment so you see what happens two
different terms ok so that defines the
problem
so the coordinates we'll call this mass
m1 keep this a little general for a
moment and this is m2 so m1 is at the
coordinates X 1 I 0 and z1 K and M 2 is
at X 2 I 0 and Z 2 ok ok just points in
a plane and I want now to compute the I
want to find the angular momentum of
this object with respect to point a
remember compute angular momentum to
pick the points so I'm going to do it
with respect to point a and that's going
to be the sum of the angular momentum of
mass 1 with respect to a plus the
angular momentum of mass 2 with respect
to a
so the angular momentum of any particle
I with respect to a is R cross P right R
cross the linear momentum so it's R I
with respect to a cross P I now the P
this is the moment momentum of the
particle that's always with respect to
what kind of frame when you compute
angular momentum must be the inertial
frame right so you know technically a
start would just remind you of that we'd
say oh but we've already said that our a
is a fixed point in an inertial frame so
it's okay to write RI with respect to a
cross in this case p i with respect to a
they're the same thing these things are
exactly the same thing the momentum
measured at any two fixed points in an
inertial frame is the same it doesn't
matter where you're measuring it from
okay and we know that p i with respect
to a now we'll call it is the mass times
the velocity of i with respect a right
that's just that's just ordinary linear
momentum so i need an expression for the
velocity of i with respect to a any
point so these are fixed now these are
fixed length things the velocity of a
moving point is just the derivative of
the position vector but you have this
little look at this equation some people
call a transport equation so the length
of this thing is not changing any so
it's just going to have one term in it
so what's the velocity in vector
notation
Omega cross all right now right and this
could also all right these are vectors
and because I can say that then I can
say H I with respect to a is M I are I a
cross Omega with respect to O cross R i
with respect to a okay all vectors so
any rigid body so here's the here's the
link now here's a jump from different
points particles to rigid bodies any
rigid body is made up of the whole mass
of particles connected rigidly together
no relative motion but whole s of
particles so I can compute the total
momentum of a rigid body as the
summation over all the little particles
in it mi RI a cross Omega with respect
to O cross R I just that is some Amala
and when you have continuous bodies
these summations turn into integrals so
you'll find definitions for you know
like there's a mass moment of inertia
are about this axis of this weight line
against mr squared over two and it comes
from the and that's the number that you
have to multiply by Omega to get the
angular momentum so it comes from
summing up all these little particles in
this thing is the total momentum angular
momentum of the
object alright let's do that we're going
to do that for our two little masses
here and see what kind of things result
I want to get my H with respect to a is
the sum of h1 with respect to a plus h 2
with respect to a and I'm just going to
use that formula so it's m1 so if I were
just work out that little vector
products there m1 here's our I a it's X
1 I plus z1 K cross Omega Z K cross X 1
I plus z1 K okay and then I have a
second term the m2 term X 2 I plus Z 2 K
Omega Z K X 2 I plus Z 2 okay so just a
lot of little vector terms that that is
that expression for our two little
particles in with their specific
positions at X 1 and Z 1 and X 2 and Z 2
so if I multiply all that out then I'll
get the following result H with respect
to a here is m1 x1 squared Omega Z K
minus m1 x1 z1 Omega Z in the I hat
direction plus an m2
x2 squared Omega ZK minus M 2 X 2 Z 2
Omega Z in the I direction so this is
the angular momentum of particle 1 this
is angular momentum of particle 2 and
I'm going to do a special case on the
special case I'm going to let M 1 equal
M 2 equal M over 2 so they'll just sum 2
m and x1 equals minus x2 and z1 equals
minus z2 so because that's existing
symmetrically opposite like drawn in the
picture but I'm making them equal masses
and equal distances on either side of
the origin right and that's going to
make this thing simplify quite a bit
this is of the form this angular
momentum vector is of the form has three
vector components in this particular
case this one's zero and we call the
first component this will of the this
one here will be H X and this one here
is clearly H Z of component in the Z
direction okay and if we draw here's our
system here's our coordinate system the
coordinate system attached to the body
it has a Z component of angular momentum
positive upwards and it has an X
component of angular momentum in the
minus direction like that and you add
them together you get that so this is H
with respect to a this is H Z this is H
X now we've got we've found this before
and when we didn't talk anything about
moments of inertia or anything we just
deal with particles earlier as we did
problems we found out that when you have
this kind of unbalance the direction of
the angular momentum vector is not in
the same direction as the rotation
vector in this case the rotation is
Omega ZK it's like that the vector is
going around angular momentum okay
and in general you would write a checks
gender with general case and this is
what you can pull off this little two
sheet handout you connect that you can
download and you have to copy everything
this is going to look like an ixx omega
x plus i XY omega y plus i XZ omega z
and so if we look at that and we look at
this this particular case the h x term
is this right so in this this is the
general expression for H X and in this
particular case that will look like
minus mx1 Z 1 Omega Z and it's this is
the piece that's in the I direction it's
probably called H X and this is this is
then I X Z Omega Z so this piece here is
what we call IX e that's where it comes
from
and we can write it so this is in this
this is our spec this is our particular
case get this result and we find there's
H in H Y is 0 and H Z is M x1 squared
Omega Z Omega Z and that's got to be
able to form i ZZ omega z now what how
do you remember what the subscripts mean
IX z means this is the H component
and this is the wrote Omega component
it's x so i XZ is the product of inertia
for HX cause thats related to rotation
in the Z component of rotation that's
within the subscripts mean and
maybe I'll do this
so in general we can oh the what these
constants are for your rigid body and
you know your rotation rate you
instantly know your angular momentum and
these things the products and moments of
inertia are basically catalogued you
find them in the back your textbook for
all sorts of different objects so I know
that promotion for okay AV if you have Z
in this direction and this thing's
rotating around Z H Z is the total mass
of the system times the radius squared
divided by 2m R squared over 2 would be
i ZZ for this object and so all sorts of
objects those are these are just
catalogued values and then there's ways
of moving the axes called parallel axis
theorem so that you've probably run into
that allows you then to construct these
values from one known point to moving
the point to someplace else and having
it move around that so these values are
tabulated calculated around with respect
to the centers of mass and if you want
to have the mass moments of inertia with
respect to any other point then you will
use something which we call a parallel
axis theorem which will which will get
to in due course ok pretty good on
timing here a note about textbooks
textbook conventions this I matrix in
some they write it I X X I X Y I X Z and
so forth I X I Y X I Y y i y z CX some
write it like that and others write it
with all of these with minus signs and
the off-diagonal terms so hitler uses
the minus signs williams that's not so
the diagonal terms are always positive
yeah all the off one all the off
diagonals are negative so lewis this is
positive positive positive positive and
then negative negative negative negative
negative negative right now they're
actually negative not bill be negative
the numbers will pop up negative and so
forth it's just that in the notation
some authors have adopted putting the
minus signs here others have embedded
them in in the value itself so williams
notation he would say that i X Z is
minus mx1 z1 for this body hitler would
say it's plus and they put the minus
sign in the in the notation okay so just
be aware of that because you're getting
all your life you're going to run into
people saying the product of inertia
this thing is and you got to know which
way they define it
all right to compute torques you just
take time derivatives of angular
momentum and we'll do we'll do that as a
last little step next time but you've
got the the essence of the movement from
talking about particles to how we're
going to talk about rigid bodies so you
have muddy cards you have two or three
minutes write down what was tough for
you here write down what it wasn't okay
and see you next Tuesday
oh I must say so this stuff about I the
this and the mass moments of inertia
matrix that stuff is not on the exam but
known about particles and particle
moments of inertia is